What's up everybody. This is Jad
radio lab surprise podcast here.
Tomorrow is the big
game. Go Eagles. And uh,
whether you like football or
not, I happen to be a fan.
But whether you like it or not,
it's one of the biggest
sporting events in the world.
And it's a game that in many ways has
always been wrapped up in what America is
and what it isn't.
And so what we thought we'd do just as
a corrective measure is bring back an
episode that we put together a couple
of years ago about the origins of that
game. It's kind of an
amazing story and look, Geek,
we're all going to be sitting
there watching Tom Brady probably,
but hopefully not win another Superbowl.
And we'll be watching timber buns do the
halftime thing. And throughout it all,
no one will be talking about the people
without whom the game would be nothing.
So this is an honor of them to story that
we got two from journalist and author
Sally Jenkins from her book,
the Real All-americans.
I mean, football, football is as old
as sort of the Celtic civilizations.
I mean, you can trace a
primal games of, you know,
Danish invaders kicking skulls
around the shores of England. I mean,
that's not a football
that's exactly different,
but organized football
is really a creation of,
of the 1860s and
seventies in this country.
It's a post civil war
creation comes along, uh,
just really a couple of
years after, you know,
the last great conquering armies
settle the West. Basically she says,
you had these kids whose parents had
fought in the civil war and then some of
them had gone west to fight the, a
Lakota, the Cheyenne, the Rapahoe,
the Apaches, and now those wars are
winding down, which oddly enough,
created kind of an issue
for young men at the time.
If you're a young student, say back
east at a fancy school like Harvard,
how are you going to prove
your own toughness? I mean,
your older brother, your,
your father, he, they may be fought.
Gettysburg, add a little big one.
What the hell have you done? The
American frontier experience was over.
There was this feeling among a lot
of intellectuals that, um, that um,
American men were losing
their masculinity.
They were being feminized in a sense.
So according to historian David Adams,
you just heard those kids were
desperate for opportunities to man up.
There was this cult of metal
around this time,
David and see a bunch of
violent sports take off.
And in particular for our purposes,
you see these kids at Harvard and Yale
getting together and
knocking the snot out of each other in
this game that's kind of like rugby,
but just more violent.
The game used to be basically brutality.
The origin of football was such a
profoundly different game, right?
A chuck Klosterman and before him
historian Dr. Conrad Crane, you know,
a first down instead of 10
yards was only five yards.
You had three downs to get five yards
and basically all the teams did okay.
Sort of slam each other
and try to move the ball incrementally.
It was almost as if every play of the
entire game was the goal line stand.
You know, w the,
the metaphor people always
use when discussing football
of course, is military.
It's the idea of taking
land and giving life. Well,
the origin of football
that was even amplified.
There were formations and
strategies and that kind of thing.
But it was pure like right out of
Napoleon's military playbook. I mean,
where you concentrate your force. Yeah.
Shoulder my shoulder next to your
shoulder, nick. The his shoulder.
I think it's a lot like
you bunch up all the,
all your man and then pierce
the other guy's army. Yeah.
That was the basic idea. And so you
just end up with piles of guys. Yeah.
And inside those piles there's all
kinds of things go on in those scrums.
I mean there's kicking in
bite and there's gouging.
I'm languaging and crotch
kicking and wow. Head wrenching.
And I remember we were talking
with Harvard boys doing this.
I have to work to imagine that because
I think of Harvard and Yale now and I
think of like, I think neck geeks.
Yeah. I don't think of him as big guys.
Well at the time they were the, the,
I mean there are all these wonderful
stories about these chops that they would
eat for dinner. I mean,
they were drinking milk by the gallon
and the Ivs were the great power of the
time physically as well as intellectually.
But then along comes this school,
this tiny little school, uh,
founded in 1879 in the middle of nowhere
that if you're a football fan or just a
fan of American history,
kind of changed everything where it
was Carlo Carlisle was in Pennsylvania,
right. Very close to Gettysburg.
Let's go there. Let's, so, so,
so tell me about a car. What is the,
when did it formed and what was it there?
The Carlisle Indian school
is formed by a former of,
well actually he was an active military
officer at the time named Richard Henry
Pratt. The guy shock of white hair,
large nose crowd, had stripped gallantly,
quite gallantly in the civil war.
And then he had actually served
out West in Oklahoma territory. Uh,
he had fought, uh,
American Indians himself.
And it was after winning a lot of
those fights, too many of those fights.
Really? No,
we're talking a 1870s now that
Pratt had a change of heart and he,
he suddenly became concerned about the
very people he had just been fighting.
The fact of the matter is that Indians
were in very, very desperate situation.
The bison were almost extinct.
They were being pushed onto reservations
and population at fallen to two.
It's almost all time low.
Uh,
Pratt, um,
and a lot of other policymakers came
to the conclusion that something had to
happen fast or Indians would
literally become extinct.
They would in fact become
the vanishing race.
And so Pratt, um, he comes
to Washington with an idea.
His idea was to start a boarding
school specifically for American Indian
children. That was kind
of a radical experiment.
Children would be taken removed
for several years at a time.
They would be stripped of their, uh,
what was called their savage heritage
and they would be civilized, I.
E they would be white enticed.
It was forcible. A Pratt had a,
a slogan, kill the Indian, save the man.
That's Barbara Landis Carlisle
Indian school biographer.
We went up to Carlisle to talk with
her and her colleague Cara Curtis,
and they told us that prep basically
made that pitch, kill the Indian,
save the man, not just to Congress,
but directly to American Indian families
all over the country. I want your son.
Is that, how does that work?
I want your children because white
people are gonna keep coming and coming.
They want to settle in your lands.
They want to take your lands and you
need to learn how to deal with these
people. So we need to teach your
children how to speak English.
We need to teach them how to communicate
with the white man so that when the
white man comes and tries to get
you to sign away the black hills,
you won't fall for it again. And
it was a convincing argument.
Well, do you know back in those days or
you're talking about survival over here?
Would you mind introducing yourself?
Okay. My name is Joe American horse.
I'm 79 years old and I'm a
grandson of chief American heart.
Joe Lives near the Pine Ridge
reservation in South Dakota.
He's Lakota and he told us the story
about his grandfather who was a famous
Lakota chief in the 1890s.
His grandpa led a delegation
of American Indians too,
Washington. Well,
he went to Washington d
C and he was down there,
but he's a lot of people downer just as
his grandpa had this moment where he was
just stunned by how many white
people there were. His face was,
they're like ants and pretty soon
they're going to come to the area.
So he had the idea of uh, trying to
send his kids to school so they can,
uh, inner mingle or you
know, intercepted, whatever.
Basically Joe says his grandpa just
had this realization, we can't,
we can't go back. We've got to go forward.
And it seemed to him
Carlisle was the way forward.
So where are we going
now? Is Our photo archive
the kids who are admitted,
here's how it would work.
They would come in and they'd immediately
have their picture taken on arrival.
Then they'd be given an extreme makeover,
which would also be photographed.
Really? Wow.
This is Tom tour, Leno. Wow. This
is, this is Tom Turley as he,
as he comes in,
Barbara showed us a picture of a
Navajo kid looking maybe 18 years old,
does 1882 this is when he arrived.
So you, he's got kind of dark skin,
high cheek bones in long
hair. Yeah. Earrings.
He's wearing elaborate necklace.
It looks like it might be made of bone
and he's wrapped in a blanket and then,
and then now here he is in a suit with
clean cut hair. And the second picture,
his hair is very short. Not
long, no blanket swearing.
A three piece suit sitting there with
a cro and a spread collar and a part at
here. Wow. It's like in a
snapshot. You have Tom Indian,
Tom White Man.
Well, and Sophie,
Joe American Horse said his family saw
that transformation firsthand and Sophie
was there and Kyle for five
years. And when she came back,
she looks like a wild woman. You know,
she had a real tiny waist and
a vomit and everything and uh,
she can't speak Lakota.
She forgot. [inaudible] it. Just
think about this for a second.
Just think about this. When we spoke
with one guy, a professor, Eric Anderson,
who teaches at Haskell, he's also part
Pottawatomie. Just imagine the parents,
he says, wow. The first time
they see their kids, parents
seeing their students marched around in
essentially the uniforms of what had not
very long before for many of the
tribes been the uniform of the enemy
at the very least.
I think that would be startling
ninny case. According to Sally Jenkins,
after the kids were re
cropped and redressed,
Brett would run them through a bunch of
drills and in Carlisle was a a little
military academy and the Indian
kids were so unhealthy at first.
They had been put on an unfamiliar Diet.
They had been sleeping indoors for the
first time in their lives and a lot of
them were getting sick.
I mean we know that in the 39
year history of the school,
at least 200 kids died of disease
or poor health or even homesickness.
And so Pratt was constantly trying to
get the kids outside and at a certain
point he had hired some teachers and
Sally thinks that one of those hires,
probably one of the
first dormitory masters,
this guy who had formerly
taught at an Ivy League school,
he showed the Carlisle Indian kids. Yeah,
this game that the kids
at Harvard were playing.
Maybe he thought it would toughen
him up. Who knows? But suddenly
they were playing football. Now
keep in mind, this is, you know,
at a point back in 1882 where
football is barely a thing,
not so many schools had teams.
There wasn't such a thing
as a head coach back then.
They were volunteer coaches who tended
to be students or ex students with the
Carlisle kids self organize
level. The field start to play.
They even start to scrimmage some kids
across town and at one of those games,
according to Barbara, Stacy Matlack,
who is a Pawnee student at Carlyle,
later became a plenty
chief. He broke his leg
playing football and precedent. That's
it. No more football because in his mind
he was trying to civilize these kids
and football was doing the opposite.
Uh,
but a short time later, since David Adams,
approximately three dozen Carlisle boys
came in to Pretz office and they said,
we want to play football.
Do we know what they said? Exactly.
We don't have, we don't have the exact
words, but Pratt says at one point,
he says,
while they stood around my desk and I'm
quoting him while they stood around my
desk, they're black eyes intensely
watching me. Um, he says,
the orator gave practically all the
arguments in favor of are contending and
outside football.
And ended up requesting
the removal of the embargo.
His memoir,
Pratt was sort of bowled over by the
eloquence and passion of the appeal.
So we said, okay, you can play if you
do these two things. One, he says,
never slung people who are looking on,
we'll say there, that's the Indian of it.
Just see them. They are savages and
you can't get it out of there. Okay.
And the other one was you have to
beat the best teams in America.
And at that early point in
American football, far and away,
the most powerful team was Yale,
which brings us to October 24th, 1896.
It's
a raw fall day in New York. I
played in New York. Yes. At, uh,
the old polo grounds barely.
There was a [inaudible]
4,000 people in the stands,
including a handful of newspaper men,
New York newspaper men, newly Jimmy was
a big story. How did they publicize it?
What did they say? Well, the
newspapers became incredibly intrigued
on one side were the undergraduate
showed an old and great university
[inaudible]
hey,
represent basically the perfection of
modern athletics or intellectually the
culture and refinement of the best
modern American life. On the other side,
let's me aborigine the real showing of
the forest and playing the red skin of
history. Story of war developed over me,
or as the case may be by education.
And if you read the newspaper stories,
they're written as they're written in
this kind of blood curdling shot through
with Indian cliches. You know, the red
skins here come the red skins, right?
Right. According to David Adams. In one
paper it was a reference to yodeling.
The writer said that then the fans
were yodeling in that Indian fashion.
I mean try to put yourself
in the shoes of a New Yorker.
In the early 1880s your contact with an
American Indian was in a wild west show.
It was theater and here comes a
football game and all of that.
These American Indian kids run onto the
field and there's literally an instance
in one of the [inaudible]
first games with someone
in the audience says, well,
they look just like our boys because
of course that's what Brad wanted.
Now one thing that was
immediately [inaudible]
clear to everyone in attendance when they
saw the Carlisle players was that they
were physically outmatched.
Yeah. Around average
weight is 164 fingers,
Shaklee 20 pounds by two to one man
and going in is that there'll
be an absolute smear job
or at the very least the
odds are heavily against him. But
three minutes into the game,
in the midst of a big pile up
[inaudible]
a Yalie fumbles the ball.
It comes squirting out.
Carlisle guy picks it up. Yep.
And runs the entire length
of the field. 63 yards
scores a touchdown.
Now nobody had scored on Yale in
seven games. They were furious.
So what they do is they use their bulk
to slowly push the pile down
the field twice to take leave.
Yeah. And
with three minutes left,
yeah. Let's up. 12 to six Carlisle has
the ball, Carlisle running back charges.
The pile in
[inaudible] gets clobbered,
falls backwards. And just as he's about
to hit the earth, he laterals the ball
to a teammate who grabs
it, runs around the scrum.
The entire length of the field score
[inaudible]
Carlisle scores a touchdown
that would have tied the game,
what
it's called back by a
referee who was a Yale man.
Why the call was that the referee claim
that a whistle had blown the play dead.
And what was the crowd's reaction?
Well, they were, they were furious. Yes.
Bullying and, and hooting.
Everyone knew it was a terrible
miscarriage of justice.
And some of the Carlisle players
said, oh, we're gonna Walk Outta here.
We are leaving this game. But
according to David at the last moment,
Pratt runs down from the stands, comes
onto the fields, is wait a second,
wait a second. Wait, don't
forget. Rule number one,
be a gentleman.
Pratt did not want this game to
end because of their tempers,
even though they'd been
wronged by a by that call.
So the Carlisle boys finished the
game and when they walk off the field
[inaudible],
they get a standing ovation. Carlyle wins,
incredible respect and renown in
the aftermath of the game. In fact,
one of the newspaper men after another
Carlisle Yale game or something
similar happened,
wrote something to the effect of
Carlisle could beat 11 year men,
but they couldn't beat 11
Yale men and a Yale referee.
Yes.
After the Yale game of
1896 pret is committed.
Pratt believes that it's the greatest
thing that can happen to his school.
It is an instant way to do what he's
been struggling to do for 15 years at the
Carlisle school,
which is to prove the value of these
American Indian kids against their white
peers, to prove the value or to civilize
them well, both to civilize them,
but also to prove that given
education and equal opportunity,
they were the [inaudible].
Cool. Have there. Hmm. That's
interesting. Their white peers,
I mean he was for all of his forcible
assimilation methods, which were,
you know, to remain extremely
cruel and destructive.
He truly believed in the
concept of, of racial equality.
The complicatedness of Pratt and of the
whole Carlisle idea kept smacking us in
the face as we were putting this show
together. I mean, on the one hand,
they were clearly students who felt that
Carlisle was prison and in fact Barbara
Landis,
when she took us on a tour of the grounds
of the former Carlisle Indian school,
she said that kids would even set
fire to the buildings. It's a, yeah,
some did down, which is kind
of typical on Indian campuses,
a lot of fires and
burning buildings. Why I,
it's a form of resistance.
On the other hand,
no, you please.
When we started looking
around for original archival
recordings of some of the
earliest Carlisle players, pretty
much the only recording we could find
has this tape. We would like for it to
be too much of your making is possible
was this oral history with
a guy named [inaudible].
Your name, your full name
is Andrew, actually nine
Albert x and Diane.
The interview was done in the early
seventies when he was 88 he entered the
school
just before 1899 you were 50 years old.
That's fair.
Can't really play you too much of this
cause the audio quality is really bad.
But in the interview, [inaudible],
r, h Prac, Pra, d, g
and x and Diane talks about them with a
great deal of affection and gratitude.
We call him the diff father
of [inaudible] education.
We call him the father of
Indian education. Yeah.
Oh, he lies. I had one wonderful man.
So he's a tough figure. Pratt, and
he's got a very mixed legacy. I mean,
I like to say Pratt was his country.
Whenever you think of him, he was
his country. So. Okay, so 1896,
he gets the bug like he sees
peak football's good PR. Yes.
What happens next? Well, he, he hires,
uh, he begins looking around for coaches,
full time coaches to come in and coach
the team. Uh, and he winds up, um,
with a, a Cornell Grad,
uh, named Pop Warner
Glen Pop Warner.
Pop Warner is an interesting guy is
this pops right here just to give you
visual. Yep. Woo. Look at his farm.
And Carrie showed us pictures. It
looks kind of like a Mike Ditka.
If Mike Ditka had Einstein's hair up,
pops a little bit of a, of an outlier. Uh,
he's, he's got these Texas roots. He's
a bit of a rogue can be kind of vulgar.
I like to party a little bit.
He liked to gamble really well and that
is exactly what he does in spectacular
fashion. When he gets to Carlyle
because pop Warner looks at,
at his squad and he realizes that,
sure, they're fast, they got heart,
but they're underweight and
they're small waist wall. You know,
while they might occasionally forced
a tie with it with a Yale if they,
you know, have killed
themselves physically,
they weren't going to beat the Ivy
Leagues on any kind of consistent basis
without, without doing
something different.
And there was a very fine line
between innovation and cheating
and pop Warner starts IX exploiting
that line. Absolutely. Uh,
as hard as he can. And
he comes up with, uh,
the trick play for example, 1903 pop
Warner devices, the hidden ball trick.
But what is that?
The hidden ball trick is
I'm the quarterback takes
the ball and actually behind
this
huge pile of men tucks it under another
guy sweater while the big pile of men is
struggling in the mud in
the center of the field,
not knowing quite where the football is,
but believing it's somewhere
in the middle of the pile.
Here's this kid who squirts around the
end with the football hidden under his
Jersey and he's 30 yards downfield
before anybody realizes it.
And how does he keep the ball
from falling out of his jersey?
I think they actually sewed the Jersey
so that the ball would stay in there
without falling out. So they made a
cheating pocket, made a cheating pocket.
Was that legal? But they got
it. Did they get a religion?
Was it legal?
You ask pop Warner would have said there
was nothing in the rule book against
it.
Another thing he does,
which actually works brilliantly is he
sows footballs onto the front of their
jerseys, which are really
bulky sweaters at the time.
He sows leather football shaped patches
onto the front of their jerseys in order
to try to disguise who's
got the ball. Really,
I guess Harvard and the
Harvard coach goes insane.
[inaudible] sent me pregnant.
This is the kind of thing,
but Harvard did not take this line down.
Harvard retaliates by painting the
football's the same color as their jersey.
It's Maroon everywhere. So when they
held the ball against their chest,
the ball basically, well you can't see it.
I mean they all broke the rules.
American football is essentially a
rule breaking experience as opposed to
British football, which
didn't have referees.
At least initially a British
football ran on the honor system,
but with American football, the rest were
there practically from the beginning.
And she says it was largely a
response to the brutality of the game,
but also to the kind of rule bending
that you saw from pop Warner and the
Carlisle Indians. Every time pop
Warner came up with an innovation,
the next year there was a rule against it.
So immediately the Ivy League would get
together and pass a rule and say, okay,
no more of that.
And that's how the rule book really
burdens in an American football.
And it's thanks to pop Warners slights
of hand and pop Warner's greatest slight
of hand and maybe the Carlisle
Indians most soaring moment.
And I mean that literally happened at a
moment when the game almost disappeared.
That's coming up.
[inaudible]
start of message. Yes, this is
David. Adam, this is Conrad Crane.
Can I get an email message
asking me to read credit texts?
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org. Okay.
There it is. If you can use that,
they care. And this message,
Hey, uh, Simon Adler here. Uh,
I'm one of the producers here at Radiolab
and I wanted to take a quick to tell
you about something
that, uh, that I think is pretty
interesting that, that we make here, uh,
besides the show. So we have a newsletter,
which I know everyone
does, but hear me out.
Unlike a lot of other
newsletters out there, uh,
we don't waste your time by just blabbing
about what our next release will be or
begging you for money. Uh, actually
we, we do a a little bit of that. Uh,
but what we also do is each
time a new episode drops,
we send you a list of staff picks,
essentially a collection of things to
folks here who make this show have come
across recently and are excited about, uh,
they range from books and music to TV
shows, youtube clips, art exhibits, blogs.
It's sort of a repository for this
stuff that's got us interested.
But for whatever reason, uh, we're not
sure how to turn into a radio story.
So if that sounds
interesting to you at all,
I hope you'll sign up for our newsletter.
It's free and you can sign up in
about just 30 seconds at radio
lab.org/newsletter or even easier to
just text r l news as in Radiolab news to
seven zero one zero one that's RL news
to seven zero one zero one and thanks.
Hey, I'm Jen Abu Moron. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab.
And getting back to our
story on the Carlisle Indian
school and the birth of the
monitor game of football, one of the
most important moments in this story,
a happens at a time when football was
right on the edge of disappearing.
Talking about 1905 this was the most
violent year in football to this point,
19 people died on the football team.
One nine one death is alon
19 that's crazy. Yeah.
Cause what would happen is that Carla
would try and do these things to sort of
open up the game.
The ivies would consistently respond by
making the game more about brute force,
more about violence.
So you had all these desks and suddenly
all the major programs were spooked.
You know, Columbia polls, their
PR or their football team.
Harvard even thinks
about doing it. And so,
and this is kind of odd
into the fray steps,
the president of the United States
of America, Teddy Roosevelt,
in order to get him, because he was
a fan, according to Conrad Crane,
he liked football. He liked
the, the manly aspects of it,
the tough aspects of it. But
nobody liked people dying.
And then there was his kid,
his, his son was playing and,
and getting beat up pretty
badly as well. Broke his nose,
slid his eyebrow and one
game he got knocked out cold.
So after the violence of
oh five the president calls
the presidents of all these
colleges and so on and to Washington
and according to David Adams,
he basically tells them that
the rules had to be rewritten.
It had to become a little bit more
safe at least, or it would be banned
out of that. We see a couple
of rule changes. First,
the schools decide in order
to loosen up the, so to speak,
they're going to tinker
with the down yardage ratio.
Instead of going from three
downs to gain five yards,
it becomes three downs to gain
10 yards. The three downs,
you get tenure to four downs to get 10
years before we'd come a couple of years
later. Oh. But the second rule change,
which is maybe the most important for
our story is for the first time they
legalize the ability to move the
ball through the free floating air.
It surrounds us all. Okay, so where do
we go watch the next day? So if I could,
if I could place you in a moment,
unless there's a moment before
this you'd like to hit. Uh,
I believe November 23rd,
1907, yes. Big Moment.
Okay. Can you set the
scene? Well, the scene
from the standpoint of broader American
history, things have gone airborne.
You mean Wilbur and Orville, right.
I'm talking about not just them,
but I'm talking about hot air balloons.
[inaudible]
there are aeronautical experiments
happening really all over the world.
In France, everyone is
experimenting with flying machines.
Things are going up in the air,
but not so fast with football because
when the rural committee had made that
rule about Ford passing,
they had also hedged a little bit saying
if you throw a forward pass and you
receiver doesn't catch it,
you are penalized 15 yards,
which back in the day was a monster
amount, so nobody threw the ball.
It was too risky. But story goes.
As soon as that rule got passed,
pop Warner goes back to his garage.
It's always a garage of quest with a
ball and he starts to experiment in any
certain thing like, okay,
what would be the most efficient
way to toss this thing?
People have to understand
that the footballs in those
days are not the footballs
we have today with the Nice, you know,
whatever that old blades spheroid or
whatever they call it with the Nice points
and things. These are rugby balls,
sort of imagine a deflated basketball.
They're thicker in the middle,
they're not as well shaped.
They're really tough to get
your hand on to throw. Right.
And in 1906 there's a tiny bit of tape
in Albert x and Diane's oral history
where he talks about this in 1906 he
says, pop called all the players together.
He tells them
high rollers, if you were to have to learn
[inaudible]
he says, I think you're going to
have to learn to spiral. The ball
does far as the ball
because if you throw the ball in a spiral,
it gets 10 times less air drag
than if you throw it end over end.
Plus it's easier to catch. Yeah. They
start experimenting with it a little bit.
And in 1906 but they come out
in 1907 as a throwing offense,
which gets us to that game.
November 23rd, 1907 Carlisle
place, the University of Chicago,
last game of the season,
we're in Chicago and the Chicago team
is arguably the best in the nation,
the best.
I don't think it's even arguable what
Carlisle is good at this point though.
Yeah. But Chicago is like stag field
and there are 27,000
people in the stance. Well,
what happened was, uh,
the Chicago players had decided to
try to defeat Carlisle's innovative,
folded passing by just knocking the crap
out of their receivers every time they
came off the line of scrimmage. And
so Carlisle's greatest receiver,
Albert x and Diane,
our guy had been stymied the entire
game because the minute the ball was
snapped,
Chicago players would hit him and try
to throw him down or knock him out of
bounds.
So pop Warner said to x and
Diane, here's what we're gonna do.
Next time they hit you out of bounds,
sneak around the bench and get
back on the field by some accounts.
This was x and Diane's idea.
But whoever thought of it on the
Albert x died as expected.
Ends up out of bounds.
[inaudible] but he keeps running.
He runs around the back of the
bench, runs around the spectators,
maybe around the band and comes back
on the field right at that moment,
Hauser the quarterback of Carlyle
lets loose a vicious spiral. Can I
have you read recently? Sure. Hold on.
This is cell, his description
of that moment from her book,
the real all American.
Yes. For a moment. It was a
frozen scene and a stage drama.
The ball hung in the air.
A tantalizing possibility
could x and Diane reach it.
Would he catch it or drop it?
Defender's wheeled and stared down.
Field spectators watching from the
stands found that the breath had died in
their collective throats.
The spiraling ball seemed to defy
physics. What made it stay up?
When would it come down?
In that long moment,
27,000 spectators mashed together on
benches and crammed on platforms may have
felt their loyalty to the home team
evaporate in the grip of a powerful new
emotion.
They may have noticed something they
never had before that a ball traveling
through space traces a
profoundly elegant path.
They may have realized something
else that it was beautiful.
The ball struck it's human target x
and don caught the pass all alone and
trotted over the Chicago gold line.
The stadium exploded in sound and motion.
It was the game breaker. The
rest was just anticlimax.
The final score was 18 to four for Carla,
but the very next year the Ivy League
passes a rule that you can't leave the
field and then come back
onto [inaudible]. Okay. Yes.
That's where that rule comes from.
I get to say that that description
of the ball [inaudible] in
the air is,
is timeless in a way.
That's exactly why football is still
beautiful at times. That's, that's,
that's when Carlisle in 1907 is when
American football becomes the sport that
you watch today.
That's exactly our style. Oh Wow.
This is this the field field.
This is the fee. Can we get out?
Yeah.
[inaudible]
after we'd spent an entire day
looking at pictures of, you know,
Albert x and dine and Pratt
and pop Warner and Dulles,
Lone Wolf and Tom Leno and
all these Carlisle players.
Barbara and Cara took us to the field
where they practiced and so this is the
Carlisle Indian school
football field covered in snow,
like 10 degrees out here. Really,
really bright sun going off
this now and it's just empty.
And we just kind of walked around
and tried to imagine all this stuff.
We'd just seen in photos. He was a
little bit like walking among ghosts.
Yeah. That's the sound of the
flag blowing in the background.
I remember standing on that field and
I'm having this thought that I couldn't
quite articulate.
Okay.
But later, Eric Anderson,
that professor from Haskell is a
member of the Pottawatomie nation.
He sort of put his finger on it
and he essentially said that like,
there's a lot of room on a football field.
I mean there's room for
anger and war in violence,
but there's also room for pride
and a kind of coming together.
That's not a Pratt coming together
where one side gets erased,
but it is a coming together. Yeah.
I mean there is a middle ground.
Clearly it's more than a game.
The stakes are higher than that.
You know,
will we as Indian people be
accepted on our own terms and
also in our ability to meet you halfway
or will we be accepted through this as
the vehicle? It's
clearly more than a game,
a lot of people to thank for this
episode. Uh, we had original music, uh,
made for us for that
episode from Morgan O'kane.
You can hear him right
here playing the Banjo.
That's Morgan O k a n e
music.com. Check them out.
Also, we had original from Austin
musician, shaky graves and the uh,
Albert Oxendine tape that we played
is from the research division of the
Oklahoma historical society.
Thanks also to the Cumberland
County historical society
in the U S Army Heritage
and education center where you can go
and see tons of photos from both archives
or you can come to us on
our website radio lab.org.
We have a ton of old
archival football picks,
a ton of those before and after pictures
from the amazing, really amazing.
And we also have a link
to Sally Jenkins Book,
which is highly recommend the real
all-americans that's on our site,
radiolab.org.
Thanks also to Reggie Kathy and to
Scott Graham to know Robin's to Michael
Churness to Matt Della Pina.
Cole wimpy to Jr McCarthy to Nick Cuppa
beat Jay Colin and Michelle Campbell at
Heber and special thanks. Very special.
Thanks to our amazing volunteer cheer
squad that came out and weathered the
Brooklyn cold to scream and Holler
and bring this story to life.
And speaking of that very special thanks
to Brenna Farrell who found the story
and produced it with us and a
productions boy from Damiano Marchetti
[inaudible].
So that was part of an episode called
American football that we put together at
radio lab a few years
back. Hope you enjoyed it.
There's more of that episode sexy,
some great interviews that happened in
the second half that you can hear it.
radiolab.org I'm jet, I boom, rod,
thanks for listening. Go Eagles.